i keith olbermann and this is the
resistance so when will the Trump
Russia's story break when we know when
will we hear when already indictments
impeachments confessions Trump's fleeing
to Elba I am actually asked these
questions even more than I asked them
myself and it has recently occurred to
me that while the Trump Russia story
might indeed be that proverbial iceberg
that is 90% underwater what we now see
is still immense there are the gigantic
headlines everybody knows Trump
boastfully giving the russians israel's
classified intelligence about isis trump
boasting to them that he had relieved
the pressure by firing james comey The
Washington Post report that the Trump
Russia investigation has now reached
somebody actively serving in the White
House Michael Flynn's attorney saying
his client would take the fifth in front
of the Senate but we also know so much
more
we know that the fired head of the FBI
testified to the House Intelligence
Committee that it is investigating and
that it is not investigating if there
are links between the Trump campaign and
the Russians but rather it is quote
investigating the nature of any links
and whether there was any coordination
we know that James Comey testified to
the Senate Judiciary Committee that the
bureau is coordinating with quote two
sets of prosecutors the main justice the
National Security Division and the
Eastern District of Virginia US
Attorney's office and that there's
reason to believe that this coordination
means a US Attorney's Office might
already have a grand jury sitting about
the Trump campaign and Russia according
to CNN we know that a grand jury sitting
in that very district issued subpoenas
to Associates of General Michael Flynn
for business records we know the two non
mainstream observers first clog Taylor
and then the former Intel officer John
Schindler said the number of FBI targets
in its Trump Russia probe ranges from
about 28 to about 42 when Watergate
resulted in 40 Nixon administration
figures or associates jailed or indicted
we know that Carl Bernstein reported on
CNN that the FBI and the Senate and
House investigators believe there is a
quote active cover-up of Trump and Rush
being run by the White House and that at
least the FBI also believes it is being
impeded by all the Trump's men we know
that the acting Attorney General Sally
Yates had warned the White House about
National Security Advisor Flynn's
vulnerability to Russian blackmail and
the next day Trump reportedly asked
James Comey whether or not he was under
investigation about Russia and he
reportedly asked for commis loyalty
we know Trump promptly fired Yates and
then tweeted about her in such a way
that led some to think he may have
broken a federal law against witness
intimidation
we know Trump ultimately fired Comey -
and then tweeted about him in such a way
that led some to think he may have
broken a federal law against witness
intimidation again we know that former
Director of National Intelligence James
clapper said the Russians should
consider the firing of Comey
as another triumph for them we know the
Trump claimed clapper had cleared him of
any collusion with Russia while clapper
said he had never said any such thing we
know that the White House seems to be
trying to throw general Flynn under the
bus still and to portray him as the man
who gave the appearance of Russian
influence on Trump's administration even
while Trump himself is still somehow
claiming Flynn is actually the victim of
democratic McCarthyism we know that
Flynn is not only offered to testify in
exchange for immunity possibly against
Trump but that he has hired a lawyer
trained in Russian history who is also
an expert in the various laws for
foreign agents and lobbyists and who was
one of the last Republican never Trump
errs still standing last year we know
that to date nobody has taken Flynn up
on his offer of testimony and to the
best analyst you could have on
presidential scandals and cover-ups John
Dean that could only mean prosecutors do
not need Flynn's testimony not even if
it would mail Trump we know from CNN and
NBC reports that President Obama
personally warned Trump not to make
Flynn his national security advisor we
know from a Daily Beast report that even
after Flynn's a ouster Trump repeatedly
asked White House lawyers if it was okay
for him to again contact Flynn anyway we
know that the Senate Intelligence
Committee has
asked for four trump associates to turn
over all their emails and documents
about Russia voluntarily or it will
subpoena them and that Carter page and
Roger stone have confirmed they have
been asked and the New York Times has
reported that so to have Flynn and Paul
manna Forge we know that man affords
bank records have reportedly been sought
by the Justice Department and that quote
Senate Intelligence Committee has
requested documents on Trump from
Treasury's money-laundering units we
know that Carter page wrote a nine page
letter to the Senate committee angrily
denying any wrongdoing while noting that
the guy US officials believe is a
Russian spy Victor Putney page admits to
meeting with him in 2013 we know that
the chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee had to recuse himself from the
Trump Russian investigation after
putting on this bizarre kabuki theater
thing involving trying to ride to
Trump's rescue with evidence it sure
looks like the Trump administration
provided to him and then he virtually
disappeared from public view we know
that the Attorney General had to recuse
himself from the Trump Russia
investigation because he stepped on his
own borscht
by not telling the truth about meeting
the Russian ambassador we know that the
White House initially identified the
opinion of that Attorney General as one
of its reasons for firing FBI director
Comey and thus the Attorney General may
have violated his own refusal from all
investigations of Trump and Russia
we know that the Trump campaign denied
that there had been any meetings between
campaign officials and Russian
ambassador kis lyac which kiss lyac
denied to and then CNN turned up
evidence of him meeting with the
Attorney General and general Flynn and
Trump a JD Gordon at the Republican
convention we know that Trump produced a
quote certified letter unquote from a
lawyer claiming he had had no business
dealings with Russia in the last decade
oh wait that actually says with a few
exceptions meaning he has had some
business dealings with Russia in the
last decade worth more than a hundred
million dollars we know that the lawyer
was the same one from the January news
conference with all those folders
supposedly full of documents and that
last year her companies Moscow office at
surely literally won an award as
Russia's top law firm we know that a
prominent golf writer now says that in
2014 Trump boasted he had access to 100
million dollars in funding for golf
courses and that trumps son Eric though
he now denies saying this explained
quote we don't rely on American banks we
have all the funding we need out of
Russia we just go there all the time
we know that one of the men reputed in
the steel dossier to be a key figure in
Trump Russia an obscure Russian diplomat
named Kalugin was confirmed to be
exactly that by u.s. intelligence that
according to the BBC
we know that the pre-election hacking
attempts on voting registration rolls in
Arizona Florida Illinois and maybe other
states was allegedly done by Russians
and was no dry run but could have been
efforts to procure the email addresses
of voters so they could be micro
targeted by specific campaign
advertising that also according to the
BBC we know that last month the British
newspaper The Guardian concluded a 43
paragraph summary of the Trump Russia
saga with this stunning conclusion one
source suggested that the official
investigation was making progress
they now have specific concrete and
corroborating evidence of collusion the
source said this is between people in
the Trump campaign and agents of Russian
influence relating to the use of hacked
material what did we know and when did
we know it
in short we know a hell of a lot about
Trump and Russia right now and no matter
what they all say the only person who
could look at this 10% of the iceberg
and say there's nothing there and really
believe that is Trump himself and he is
nuts
I don't know when there are indictments
or somebody cracks or somebody cuts a
deal or all three could be six hours
from now could be six months there could
be sealed indictments now but if the
Trump Russia scandal is an iceberg and
the 10% to 90% ratio holds Trump Russia
is an iceberg big enough to sink about
200 Titanic's and nearly as many trumps
peace